hello everyone and welcome back to the
opera euro rapid preliminaries it's
magnus carlsen versus anish geary and
after two games with the black pieces
magnus finally gets the white pieces and
already we have a very big surprise uh
on move
one so without further ado let's check
it out as magnus with the white pieces
opens
with e3 and everyone was uh very
very interested as the is this some
super kind of a secret preparation
magnus prepared for geary uh is it maybe
a mouse slip or is maybe magnus even
afraid of
going e4 as well everyone is afraid of
geary's night of defense nowadays
so uh well we'll have to wait for the
end of the day too for magnus to answer
that
uh let's check out what happened here so
magnus opens with e3
so far now we know nothing of this
maneuver
uh also known as the vancouver it's
opening we have d5 by geary
and c4 by magnus uh we have e6
and now knight to f3 we have knight f6
and b3 now preparing to finca to the
light square bishop
uh c5 by giri and now bishop to b2 and
we've basically transposed into the
english opening we have knight to c6
and now a trade in the center c captures
e captures and the bishop
to b5 by magnus we have bishop to d6
geary prepares the castle
and the both players castle so castles
castles and now
uh d4 is kind of the the main idea here
but magnus goes for bishop captures on
c6 instead
and now you have to be a little bit
careful here because you no longer will
have a bishop to retreat to e2 so
b captures in c6 and now there are some
games where d3 and queen to c2 were
played however here magnus goes for
knight to c3
and now he basically invites agiri to
pin the knight which he does he plays
bishop to g4 and now you don't have a
bishop to
uh you know play bishop back to e2 and
you can't really move the queen
otherwise um
gear will just open up open up the
king's position
so here you might consider but why not
h3 and g4 i often do this in my games
because here it
doesn't work here you can just play
characters captures continue having this
pin and then the queen is coming to f6
and it's just gonna be a terrible
terrible
uh position for for white to play in the
long run black should win this
uh so instead after bishop g4 magnus
said all right i'm going to open up this
diagonal and i'm going to prepare to
bring this knight to g3 and
even if you capture here for example
captures captures i can always bring my
knight to g3
and i'll defend this way uh however giri
goes uh uh instead of capturing right
away he goes
knight to e4 now gary's idea is if
magnus
continues with knight to g3 i'm gonna
mount the pressure with knight to g5 now
having a double attack here
is going to be very good for me however
after knight the e4 magnus doesn't go
knight to g3 he goes d3
he tries to get rid of gary's knight and
now giri has a choice whether to go
knight to g5 and uh play some knight
capture screen characters where it's
really really looking dangerous for
white or to go for the instant capture
and this is what giri does after d3
geary captures on f3 we have g captures
and
now queen to g5 with check we have
knight to g3
uh if you play king to h1 then it's just
game over queen to h1
threatens checkmate and also uh knight
captures an f2 with
check and you cannot defend against both
threats if you play some like f4 the
knight captures here with
check you have to capture with the rook
otherwise you lose the queen
and this is just game over this is a
completely winning position for black
so here we have knight to g3 by magnus
and now uh giri doesn't think twice
before doing it and you don't even have
to pause the video to know what gear we
played here
of course he traded everything we have
knight captures on g3
h captures and now of course bishop
captures on g3
we have captures captures magnus doesn't
really have a say in this and
queen captures on g3 with check king the
h1
and now of course giri forced a
repetition of moves uh queen h3 king g1
check check check check check check
check queen g3 check
and it was in this position the players
agreed to a draw or rather
a three-fold repetition occurred so uh i
don't know what happened there was the
e3
uh move by uh by you know intent or was
it maybe a mouse like but it's kind of
hard to believe that magnus has
at least one mouse slip in every game i
mean it'd be it'd be pretty weird i've
seen him play bullet he does not do
mouse slip so
i think e3 was maybe some sort of a
weird uh weird uh move to throw geary
off guard
but giri it would seem is prepared even
for that move
uh sure uh crazy stuff uh giri gets an
easy draw with the black piece against
the world champion and magnus doesn't
really take advantage of his white
pieces in his first white game
on the second day but yeah crazy stuff i
hope
i hope you guys enjoyed that as magnus
surely hasn't but
two more rounds to go in uh in the
second day so uh we'll see what happens
here
uh so i would like to thank von mir
marriage federico ferrari
uh connor davis and johannes lalos for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual uh you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day